let's talk cash next because one big
announcement you'll remember at cop was
from the former head of the bank of
england mark carney he announced 450
financial firms would use 130 trillion
dollars huge amount of money to invest
in areas helping to achieve
net zero this is what he had to say up
in glasgow city you've been working on a
project to stop funding for new fossil
fuels is this what mark carney's plan is
partly about
it isn't specified yet but it's an
excellent start so at the cop26 climate
action plan the group i co-founded over
six months ago we've been talking for a
very long time about how important it is
to draw a line under further investments
in fossil fuels
effectively we were asking for a debate
to be had at cop26 asking global leaders
to stop financing new fossil fuels you
can't claim to be in transition if
you're still growing the fossil fuel
industry what mark connie's group has
done is spectacular they've managed to
gather 450 of the world's largest
organizations financial financial
organizations who have a net combined
asset base of over 130 trillion dollars
and these firms have effectively agreed
not to support any new fossil fuel
investments this is a game changer it
sounds fantastic doesn't it but jen is
it transparent do you think who's going
to monitor this
oh i'd love to be kind to my fellow
canadian mark carney but it's tough to
know i mean they're saying net zero by
2050 and there's no short term plans in
here that tell us how they're going to
get there there's no plans to report
back so we know exactly where that
money's going and there isn't a lot of
detail around what they're counting as
climate finance
so we don't know what's going to happen
yet it's it's a long-term promise and
without short-term plans to get us there
we won't know if we hit it until 2050.
which is too late yeah it's a long way
off um chidi the private sector then
managing to pivot 130 trillion dollars
which is just a huge amount of money but
governments around the world still
struggling to find that hundred billion
which is a lot smaller a year for for
vulnerable countries
that's an exceptionally good question
and just to support what gen was just
saying the plans are not smart they're
not specific measurable accurate
relevant time related that's because
they're new um they haven't been adopted
by cop but this starts the conversation
and and you're absolutely right um being
able to have funds available for for
loss and adaptation is an absolutely
essential uh a step that has to be taken
the hundred billion that was promised
hasn't been reached but it's so much
lower than where we need to be so again
at the cop2600 action plan we did our
numbers and we came up with 2.2 trillion
per annum and luckily people like mark
carney have come out and said that
number is even too low we need to go
even further so i think we're actually
in the stage of negotiations where 2050
will be challenged we need 2030. funds
will become available both from
government and from private sector
this is the beginning of a really
interesting change we are potentially
turning the titanic around so yes i'll
absolutely admit this is just a start
but it's an exciting one
okay good to end on some positivity
there but just before we go jen i want
to bring in the thoughts of sarah jane
ahmed she's a climate finance adviser
for vulnerable countries you can see
what she had to say at cop she said the
message coming out of this cop is every
country for themselves now that is
pretty damning jen i mean would you
agree with that
yeah finance at the last cop was really
difficult the fact that developed
countries couldn't make good on a 10
year old promise for 100 billion just
dismantled any trust that there was
between countries
and the fact that they couldn't talk
about finance for the permanent effects
of climate change for permanent losses
and damages
that means that there was no hope really
for developing countries feel like
they're being supported they're being
told don't develop with fossil fuels but
we're not going to provide you support
for another path oh and all those
climate damages you're currently
experiencing there's no money for that
either
so yeah i could see why a lot of
developing country delegates left
thinking they're in it for themselves
kitty
judd is absolutely right i mean that the
whole idea of making progress on this is
we do some international solidarity
the context of doing this is that up
until this cop for 25 cops before this
we couldn't even get the words fossil
fuels entered into the you know the
subway for policymakers we've changed
that and we now actually have a private
sector that wants to help the
governments who have absolutely failed
on their commitments to deal with the
rights that they they they claim they've
acquired but if we live in a world in
which we're going to make transition
quickly we have to actually fund it so
the idea that mark carney can corral the
private sector to help governments is
something we have to welcome and push
forward together on